you're one of the guys with this
pandemic you just powered do it you
weren't
you know talking about leaving or oh no
i chill complain well the good thing is
like
i you know i i i always feel like
whatever job i get
is going to be the last job i ever have
so which has made me frugal and you know
i i got an investor and i
my money's in the bank and so this
happened and i was like you know what am
i going to do
and then i was like oh i'm all right
then i just started doing other little
things
and then things things worked out i
started streaming eric griffin gaming
um yeah i see you on that twitch yeah
eric griffin gaming on twitch every day
then
did you shoot the workaholics movie yeah
no they haven't done it yet i think
they're still writing it
damn or they or maybe they made it and
i'm not in it
because adam told me about it you you'd
stream playing games yeah i started
streaming and then i got like a bunch of
uh opportunities because of it like i
did a show where i played games with
t-pain
then i did this other show because
amazon owns twitch so they got tons of
money
so they have all these like uh they got
all these like little things that they
do and
there's this lucrative listen i do i did
let me just say this i made more money
gaming in the gaming world than i did at
stand-up the year before
you know what i mean there's major money
yeah there's a lot of money in twitch
leah bryan trying to learn videos i know
whatever for money
are you playing specific video games i
always play call of duty but i'll play
other but i mostly play call
of duty yeah i'm a fun funny guy playing
video games yeah i'm not terrible
but it's like that's not you know when
those kids call him uh
the racial slur and he's like all right
and just lit them the [ __ ] up
dude that happens all the time dude this
thing they do
i have this funny video up right now on
tick tock uh that's uh
air griffin gaming it's um
you kill someone and then they turn the
mics on for like three seconds
after you kill him after you kill him
and so this guy he says to me he goes
he goes i'm coming back for you camping
[ __ ] you know
then i said i didn't hear me but i was
like okay you know i'll be waiting you
know
[Laughter]
but that but you get a lot of stuff man
you get you they say a lot of crazy [ __ ]
on the kill cams and a lot of a lot of
times it's racial i was like just white
kids being racist you know what i mean
it's like youtube coming up they're just
trying to let it out if america is
racist
this is the time i could [ __ ] really
do it or sometimes the kids that's true
there's one there's one kid that's one
little kid
you could tell he was a little kid he
gets killed and you hear him say he goes
daddy stop touching me you know what i
mean oh no but they're just trying to be
funny
yeah you know what i mean they're just
trying to be like true because you can't
really trace it back to them
if they're not really known on the
platform right yeah this i don't even
post a lot of stuff and look i posted
this video
of the of this thing and it's like more
likes than i ever
you know yeah would you get would you
keep doing stand-up if i gave you
30 million dollars no you would not you
stop
i'm out i'm almost 50. i'm done
i think i want to deal with that [ __ ]
you don't like the road anymore people
no
i would do it like dude i i'll tell you
i was hanging out with ray romano during
this movie so we're hanging out he's
telling me about
he does stand up four times a year god
damn four and a quarter
four times a year okay he goes to the
mirage four times a year and that's it
that's how you want to do this he's such
a vet like wait and he's telling me like
this too he goes he goes
he goes you know yeah we fly in on
thursday blah blah blah do the shows
like golf
ball and then sunday and night after the
show and he's being real
modest he goes you know we you know we
fly home on a private jet you know
i said right you earned it bro oh yeah
yeah
don't you don't don't feel bad that you
flying on a private jet yeah i'm trying
to get there
right you let me know that that's the
end goal but it's i'm like it's fine
so what i'm saying is if you're getting
30 million dollars i'm trying i'm going
to the great wall of china i'm going to
[ __ ] get that going everywhere you
head to china
all kinds of stuff are you uh have you
been doing stand up around l.a have you
done spots yeah i'm doing all these
little spots
yeah supernova i do the comedy store
comedy store's not the same
guys it's just not the same yet that
weird spacing and
you know i don't know i think that once
the place opens up and
i think the or and the main room were
probably like a little weird but the
belly room
been pretty dope yeah but it's probably
still not the same it's not the same
it's not a hangout spot anymore it's
like that that hey day that
last five six years whatever that was
it'll be one of those things we look
back on
oh yeah you know be like oh wow i
realized this time really i didn't
realize that at the time until it was
gone it was a renaissance
yes for sure for sure so yeah but i've
been doing a lot of shows i've done them
but so
you still do the podcast listen you're
not talking about you earned
money over time in your business doing
your business and then you
you still do that business you're
talking about you won the lottery
the lottery let's say the lottery's at
yeah 500 million
yeah they drop it you win it on
wednesday's lottery
bye you know yeah
it's not like because that's like one of
those things where here's a gift and you
go okay now let me reevaluate whatever
you just stopped doing everything though
i don't know maybe i'm just saying that
right now i know we take a year off he's
missing bro
i think that's what you mentioned this
past year i i didn't stop
yeah oh see well there you go i i was
forced i was at home
maybe if i stopped doing it i would
never come back i have a weird love-hate
relationship with all the whole business
that's what i'm like
when you're on the road non-stop yeah
like if you go three weekends in a row
or four weeks in a row you're like
traveling yeah traveling is the worst
yeah that's the worst
you know what if you could fly private
no here's what i would do if you gave me
all this money i still want to do
stand-up but then it would be like
i would it would be one week in a month
it would be it would be
the nice way i would do it like
chappelle's doing it you know maybe i
have i'd
build a farm someplace that's mine with
a theater and i'd private jet everybody
in
all my friends and it'd be like a
festival every weekend yeah you know
something like that you know what i mean
take all this money and be like hey let
me buy the comedy store
no matter what the cost tell me how much
you want for it you want 200 million
dollars here's 200 million dollars i'll
take it all
yeah and then it'll be like you know
then it's like this is the spot yes you
can go yeah yeah you know what i mean so
i mean i get that but it's like this
grind of the business right like i just
went through this whole thing man i
booked the pilot we shot the pilot it
didn't get picked up
all the emotions i went through through
all that i'm like oh my god do i want to
go through this and
keep going through this i am going to
keep going through it but it's like
you're saying here's the alternative
here's the 30 mil
but a lot of guys when they get super
famous like they're stand up communes
by trait and then they book a movie and
they blow the [ __ ] up they stopped doing
stand up
oh that's like the old days man yeah but
it's also like you can kind of
understand like you're probably sick of
the grind man yeah
i never get sick of writing and come up
with new ideas right that's what that's
the part
i don't give a [ __ ] about anything else
like what i really love is but that's
not the thing i'm trying to right now
and it's such a [ __ ] i sit there
and stare at a wall but when i get a
little
when i figure something out and surprise
myself i'm like that's that's what i
live for yeah but yeah
[ __ ] don't you have like that's just
an itch to like you we have these
thoughts and as an entertainer as a
performer as an artist because that's
what it is
you just you want to actually you want
to show that art you don't just yeah
paintings just to be like leave it in a
basement no i don't want anyone to see
this
no i'm not doing stan i'm not doing this
yeah my thing is different my thing i i
want to see what's in me like i i'm
i i don't know i'm always afraid i'm not
going to be as good as i could be like
that maybe that's what oh see i know
what keeps you going
yeah yeah yeah like i want to know what
i'm capable of i want i like to surprise
myself and i love when i write an hour
and it all seems to be thematic and i
didn't even know what was happening
and that's when and that's when you're
not looking for laughs either anymore
yeah you're just that's when you do
you're like a
true connection yeah they're laughing
because they agree or disagree with you
and all that kind of stuff and that's
just
you know so yeah you're always going to
have the itch for that i mean i love
that i like challenging myself i like to
let me see what what is the most
outrageous thing i can say on stage to
make a point
that most people wouldn't be able to say
you know what i'm saying i try to do
that don't always succeed but i try to
do that
and that's you know you're pretty damn
good at it you know what i think
that well it's about i'm you're obese
i'm also into like maybe i'm also into
just
like when what it takes to get really
good like i go down these [ __ ] gordon
ryan john donahue
these uh rabbit holes it sounds weird
your life jitsu what i love about it
is it's such an art like those
[ __ ] take it like gordon ryan
doesn't even look like he's moving much
but like when you watch john donahue
talk about technique like the details
it's mastery of something and i think
you learn a lot about life when you
masturbate and does that inspire you
like in in every standard yeah yeah but
there's anybody that's like that
there's this kid his name is jay god on
on youtube and he's a gamer guy
his name is jay god you know and but he
is the biggest
video game nerd and what he does is he
breaks down
like every gun in the game and he does
these videos where if you play call of
duty you're like
i gotta go find out what jacob's into
he's so it's that
kind of thing it's the kind of like yeah
yeah it's gotta
people like you know he'll he does these
videos like
top 10 loadouts to use and and you go
well what is this
but it's kind of like fantasy football
yeah the kind of guy that's like a stat
cruncher
the super greek this is this guy he's a
geek foreign